today of the workshop and the second day
of fully homomorphic encryption and
applications they're very happy to start
with with URI polikov who is who's a
research scientist at at at NJIT and and
at duality technologies so URI will tell
us about practical matter space to
travel free in the palisade library URI
take it away
thank you note I would also like to
thank the organizers for making this
workshop happen I know it's very
challenging so in this talk I will focus
on state-of-the-art algorithms and
latest results from the perspective of
palisade and from the perspective of
their practicality so some of the
algorithms that we will present here are
already published and and I'll just
provide references there are some new
results as well that have not been
published in papers but have been
incorporated in town site so these
results are come from joint work with
Andre Kim from New Jerseyans of
Technology and then 20 s papadimitriou
from duality technologies so the
high-level so first I want to start with
a high-level overview and we will have a
couple of introductory slides about the
type of lattices that are implemented in
palisade and which lattice schemes are
implemented just to give a background
when this games in question the main
part of this talk will be about fhc
algorithms about fhc schemes and
significant focus will be placed on the
residual number system representation CC
representation because it's quite
relevant for modern schemes for many
popular schemes and the two of the four
topics that are highlighted in bold and
that will be the core of the
presentations are BF e r NS variants and
we're going to discuss from through all
the reasons there as well then we're
going to present
we're going to discuss fica's R&S
appearance and we'll present the new
variant that in our opinion is quite
useable and addresses some of the
challenges of our nurse variants of CES
we will also provide comparison of PGD
and BFD some of those results I think
might not be treadle and we will give a
comparison of few and gfh chief so based
on recent work with any other then we
will briefly go over some of the multi
party functionalities baltic that we
have in palisade and closer to the end
of the presentation I will give a very
quick review of additional capabilities
not related to fhe so what we call
latest gadget toolkit and the protocols
based on it in first we'll start with
basic facts on latest as implemented in
palisade and we support the katana
creeks and we support Curie integer
lattices so those are the two standards
basic clear mathematical objects that we
support them from the widest perspective
and during implementations that are
available in Palace 8 are all based on
power of disick atomic rings for various
reasons of efficiency and adoption of
this in the homework equation the Doric
standard however general cyclotomic
rings are also supported but more at the
lower level we're not using any special
kappa be able to say any capabilities
that they provide to us I just I'll just
a side remark and interested in
exploring this more in the future as
long as we can get an agreement on how
secure general cyclothymic rings are and
all protocols that are implemented in
palisade are based either on elderly or
ring l ee we do have some constructions
based on SAS but as was shown in
previous talks essentially these to
block these problems are equivalent to
each other and one important remark for
ring associationism
please modulus queue that is either
prime or a product of primes and and
this prime satisfy certain constraint
that they have to be Congre to one madam
aware M is the secret ohmic further in
this case and the main motivation for
this is to provide efficient number
thoroughly transport capability so as
far as the latest schemes that are
implemented in Palestine essentially all
five schemes that we heard about
yesterday which are the most popular
schemes are implemented so this includes
the DfE we have to R&S variants this
includes BG we've also in earnest and
two RNs variants of CK Kia's and in this
stop will actually talk in detail about
one of the harness variants Percy capias
and then also we have the few M tfhe
scheme so that's an alternative they can
call this become in China and so what
you got your giveaways which can schemes
that we'll also discuss in this paper
maybe I'll give it more of a
practicality remark just a very
high-level remark on these schemes and
the first three b fe b je viens shakyas
in my opinion are very very practical to
the extent that they're currently used
in commercial products so and i see that
as a major advancement for the flattest
field that these three schemes are
already used in in in commercial
applications I'm extremely interested in
there whew and tfhe scheme so they
provide certain capabilities that like
related to comparison for instance that
we do not have with the three other
schemes
what's I mean what's the best way to it
was from them I'll speak from my
perspective what's the best way to
integrate them in commercial products I
think is for me it's loose it's still an
open question I see them more as part of
hybrid solutions that involve
one of the three core schemes are
multiple of the course games and using
you and tfhe for certain operations
it's a certainly different very
interesting field and maybe the main
limitation that I see with a few Nghe is
because the moment is the lack of
support of CRT backing so there is one
more scheme that's supported stay less
time feels feel based on the entry
assumption but it's typically not useful
for deep computations so it's more for
historical reasons we impose it we also
support multi-party homework encryption
except with extensions and specifically
one of them's brought your encryption
which has been available how's it since
the very beginning and another threshold
fhe approach which can be significantly
more efficient alternative to multi key
fhe approaches such as the one we saw
yesterday so we have been supporting
this functionality and will continue to
improve it I think there is some
interesting I mean there are some
interesting applications there in
addition to this fhe based schemes there
is a question on chat which is what
which commercial applications are be
Phoebe TVs kks Houston so I just one
second I'm just gonna bring up the
shelter as well just for that's okay so
there are specific specifically the
technologists as secure query capability
encrypted sequel like query and
basically those for instance bajillion
be a few schemes are used there and
there are also some statistical
capabilities that duality provides that
are basins yes
so those are the ones that I'm aware of
where palisade is used for commercial in
commercial products okay thank you okay
so there so when it schemes input so
further other schemes that are
implemented in palisade
so
in addition to fhe base teams we have
several schemes based on latest
trapdoors and starting with the simplest
Gendry power junkie jonathan digital
signature and ending with a certain
efficient capabilities based on ggh 15
so this protocols were developed as part
of the DARPA safe were program and well
I think there is some interested in
specifically these trapdoors and more
general - trapdoors and I'll briefly
talk about those at the end of this
presentation so one of the major theme
of this talk is the use of RNs and
double CRT and it's very important for
these three schemes they I mean vfe
bajillion CVS that work with large
integers and it's also relevant first
for other applications based on -
trapdoors such a sophistication or such
as key policy attribute based encryption
and the conventional solution that is to
use multi precision arithmetic to
support those large integers is
typically inefficient and we all started
with this multi precision arithmetic
except me before actually we're shy and
Victor initially started with the
authority but the original versions of
GBS of DfE they were all multi precision
and we saw that this approach is gets
very challenging especially as we
increase the size of integers so now
instead we use residue number system or
Chinese remainder theorem presentational
well sometimes referred to as
transferred the presentation of
polynomial coefficients and we do it for
the following reasons first rns works
with so-called native
basically integers so the ones that are
filled in the machine of word size and
we saw just from the
perspective that could speed up things
up to 10x or so also the nice aspect of
RNs is that the runtime skills are
almost linearly with integer size which
is important as we get into deeper
computations are and there are also some
hardware benefits such as or I would say
low-level benefits such as that aren't
as dramatically improves memory locality
computations are easily parallelizable
and rner supports of course efficient
hardware implementation maybe since we
are going the to advanced we're going to
present very specifically fenc gears or
based on or not I want to very briefly
explain what double CRT is what RNs is
so in ring constructions we typically
use number theoretic transform to
perform efficient polynomial
multiplication so one of the two CRTs in
this demo security concept is refers to
the polynomial it could indeed year then
the other side that's the main focus of
this talk is around the representation
of large integers and in this case we
represent the large integer as a product
of pairwise co-prime native integers
typically of size between 20 and 60 bits
and in addition to being come prank very
often we choose those moduli to actually
be the primes satisfying special entity
properties and then these large numbers
or we can think of as polynomial
coefficients or represented using CRT as
residues mod Q I so Q is our small
modular and this CRT decomposition which
is often called
R&L so that's that's what the term or
iners refers to is the second basically
CRT there are CRT in the demo security
notion so this is where that name comes
from
so the BFG scheme is especially
challenging for RNs and
and I'll explain in which regards and
there are certain operations that are
can be done very efficiently in CC RT
directly and they're actually trivial
they're done independently for each
smaller attitude and this operations in
include so this is this operation signal
addition multiplication that what a
morphism so they either done company
twice and then there are certain
operations that require extra work and
that require estimating this scale the
magnitude of the number and typically we
do not know the scale of the number when
working with RNs residues because
they're independent channels and one of
such problems is the scaling that we see
here in the case of vfe decryption and
the biggest challenge is how to
basically apply the scaling by T divided
by Q and T in this case is the point X
modulus Q is the cipher text modules how
do we can we do this operation so the
other challenge that we have indicated
vfe is scaling in homomorphic
multiplication there we do a tensor
product of the ciphertext and
polynomials without module reduction so
using effectively double bit width and
then we have to scale this big number by
something roughly comparable to Q and
one more operation that actually applies
to all three schemes that bgd BFP nches
is the I mean you can think of it as
digitally decomposition or kg
decomposition it's a very high-level
idea is that we need to take one of the
polynomials and decouple decompose it
into digits and that's in the classical
formulation that requires going back to
multi precision representation so to
address these concerns to RNs variants
of bfv
have been proposed and actually
implemented in both of the
dr. Moise versions of both days are
currently implemented palisade so the
first one is the variant that is based
only on integer arithmetic and
internally to use a small Montgomery
duction and some artillery moduli and
there are other approaches HTTP variant
uses both integer and floating-point
arithmetic and the main differences in
the Ernest procedures I mean the main
differences between those two variants
are in the RNs procedures used for
decryption and multiplication the
digital composition is solved in the
same way that was originally proposed in
the HC world and so until very very
recently it was believed that the HBS
variant has a certain practical
limitation that it needs to his extended
floating-point precision such as long
doubles or quite floats to support
moduli that are larger than 45 beats
with what say up to 6 or 64 bits
available for negative operations and
the other result was that it's part that
DHT variant may have a higher noise
growth as was observed in one of the
previous papers and actually we're going
to present some results showing it both
of those are no longer true so the HBS
rns variant there the high-level idea
might be in is relatively simple so
we'll look at the actual CRT
representation over large numbers so
large integer acts in this case and we
just basically write the regular CRT a
reconstruction as we're used to in the
the only say challenging part is that
when we do not apply mod Q 2 beta 2 to
this to this expression we have a
certain number of overflows of few as
when we come when we compute the sum and
this number of overflows is represented
this using this new or new product
depending on the formula
of the circular construction and
actually that that new is basically
somewhat of a challenge when we talk
about some RNs procedures so the
high-level idea of a specifically HTS
variant is to write down all those
expressions substitute those expressions
when we need them and then decompose
they have results in the integer and
floating-point parts and and do some
matrix there so let's see how we apply
those to the scaling and decryption do
you really question but where are the
floating points in the in this formula
it sounds like sort of everything is a
is an integer at least the second
formula yes yes so far everything is an
integer and both are an experience that
I mentioned basically start from this
for most we introduce floating-point
arithmetic for intermediate computations
so the idea is we can do some floating
point tricks but for the intermediate
computations will always go back to the
integers after that to simplify the
object to develop really simple
operations come on can you give an
example of what what an intermediate
computation is you'll see it in the
Justice life okay so so this is going to
be a bit example so the scaling in
decryption so we're so in this case
let's think of X that X is a represents
a coefficient of a polynomial in the
that we get as a result of the
decryption of operations for instance
easy robust c1s in the case of these
three schemes so it just representative
coefficient so we substitute one of the
CRT expressions in this case and it's
it's can be easily shown that this part
basically is eliminated automatically
because it's when it's going to be
multiple of T for the point X modules so
we can I need you to discard this part
and the part that
left is only the first term and after
just applying basic simplifications we
get to this expression and this is where
we start we use their floating point
trips in the decryption operation we
take so we represent this with basically
the expression in parentheses as we
split it into integer part and floating
point part so the integer part
essentially is the result of the floor
division you can see do it extracting
that way and then the rest is that does
not we're basically that's related to
the remainder of what we get is
represented as a floating point number
so theta I is in this case a floating
point number that wheels and after and
so effectively that's how we perform the
computation which was just written here
is we substitute these numbers we do
certain pre computations that they at
the pre computation stage we use some
larger numbers but during the main
computation of decryption we don't and
we're able to avoid the use of any
multi-position everything in in
computation and there is a challenge now
that in the challenge is related to the
approximation error accumulating from
rounding from performing the part that
deals with the floating point apart
maybe just before I get into I mean
explaining this further
you know this answer your question
because this is just one example
yeah and there will be another example
afterwards so it's like it we can do
certain things using floating point
arithmetic that in here and play are
dealing with multi precision arithmetic
but of course some air can be
accumulated but we find ways to either
make this error go away or it already
becomes not relevant order because the
noise is higher so when we deal with
floating point computations we can a
certain air and in this case the error
term so X I'm basically sum of X I
multiplied by epsilon I has to be less
than 1/4 to basically to preserve the
correctness of decryption and just for
the case of doubles we can restrict this
epsilon I to something 2 to the power of
minus 50 to just since that's natively
available and if we restrict this side
the killing which is how many small
moduli we use in the large module 232
then the highest module it says that we
can support with doubles is 45 and if we
need something higher and 60 60 bit
module are preferred for instance in bf
implementations we need to use either
long doubles or further quad floats
so the first new algorithm presented in
this in this talk is can you go back one
slide
sure so what is it is it is it theta I
scaled by q qi just like we
which one your lips on I'm yours person
about it tonight on ice that is a double
play
basically the era of double simply
speaking so whenever we perform any
computations with doubles we achieve one
side 52 bits of precision so this is any
air that we accumulate from Colonel sir
I see and the excise they're not they're
not necessarily their own bits right
there each X is at most qi that is
correct
so imagine desired scenario would be Q
is roughly 60 bits with or 62 this
depending on the basically
implementation and we would have a
16-bit number multiplied by this ear and
you can see that this sum can become
very hard and much much larger than 1/4
right okay so they so the new algorithm
were presenting in this talk and it's
currently implemented in palisade is how
to eliminate this problem of using quad
floats over long doubles and actually
the idea you know it comes from your
earlier work on digital composition and
just the standard 83 that's used in key
switching hopefully be real 11 is the
first word that mentioned it but that's
to the best of my knowledge and we
simply decompose excise in ten digits I
mean in this case it's sufficient to use
two digits high and low and we
introduced the digit size of basically
our beads in this case and we write down
this expression basically we explain in
two digits and we independently compute
do some pre computations for the low
digits and for the high digit
essentially the same idea the high-level
goal is to reduce the magnitude of X I
which would be 60 bits in a previous
case to something would seem like 30
bits in this case if we split it in two
so that's that's the high-level idea
and so it's after this
during decryption we have to compute
slightly more I mean it looks like
slightly what in reality is comparable
to what would previously had and so I
think it went a little bit too fast so
the air in this case is I mean the
approximation error that we get is
basically sum of two errors and the main
difference is that exile or exile hands
basically up to 30 bits in this case and
it's very clear that this sum will be
substantially less than 1/4 for any
reasonable choice of moduli that we can
support so something that worth noting
although we increase the number of
operations in this case in most
practical scenarios we actually
eliminate any modular reductions because
these numbers are small such as X i we
can perform all operations without any
modular reduction so it's playing
multiplications and additions so this is
some in terms of performance the basic
performance is very comparable to the
approach without using digital
composition even for smaller modular may
be a side note just like some other rms
procedures or propose an HTS work this
is the general trick so it's we first of
all we can generalize it to any number
of digits if you need it for a given
application if our goal is to reduce the
floating-point approximation error in so
and whenever we can think of it this way
so whenever we have a problem where we
are working with the floating points in
as an intermediate step in someone to
support modular integer computations we
can always use that trick to reduce the
precision for floating point
computations so from the practical
perspective this
remove the requirement in palisade for
any basically extended precision
floating point numbers there is a hand
rise during the chat okay you see that
so in the chat what we just it's a
little bit icy Q&A let me try to access
the church just a sec cause I don't see
the chat window sorry maybe the person
can ask a question so let me see
so the inmates a I think this one so
it's just a false positive okay fine
might not it sorry okay yeah I know how
much I just brought up there okay so
let's continue so one more step so this
is not new this is but I still wanted to
present it for completeness
so the crt-based extension another major
problem that was addressed in HP s paper
also directly works with one of the
reconstruction that we discussed so
let's say we want to extend to modulus P
we write it down the reconstruction
itself with modular P and the biggest
challenge that we have in this situation
is in estimating the value of this new
because that's the number it's an
integer that represents the number of
overflows and in in this particular
scenario basically I mean this the value
of new can it can be easily shown
basically it can be computed using this
expression and in the computation itself
we use again both integer and
floating-point numbers and but this is
not another case where a floating-point
numbers come up and in this year T basis
extension the biggest challenge is the
actual this estimating inverse so as
long as as soon as we know new and the
rest can be easily computed by using
integer arithmetic in this case for
estimating new we can use
intermediate floating-point steps I mean
the details are not mentioned here for
conciseness but they're presented in the
paper so and the approximation are
introduced I mean from the practical
perspective in case of homework
multiplication is essentially negligible
so something that I want to show so this
is the I wanted to show just how fast is
vfe with and this the results are
somewhat faster than what was presented
in the HBS paper about probably my 2 X -
3 X specific row and maybe the main one
there - I think interesting observations
from this table so the first observation
that even when we go to the let's say so
L in this case represents a number of
levels the effective depth of the
computation and it's the ring dimension
low Q of course is how many bits we have
in the ciphertext boils and K is the
number of small Prime's so we can see
that even in the case of depth 50 or I
mean well I would say get one start with
depth 20 we are getting some very
reasonable numbers under 100
milliseconds which means we can support
relatively deep computations level
computation and EFV and we can even
support computations that are basically
much larger than that but at that point
bootstrapping is probably it will become
something that can speed up the
computations the other aspect that i
would like to highlight this is because
we're going to come back to it when
talking about Vegeta vs. bf here is the
cost of multiplication so so the so I we
listed here three primitive operations
addition multiplication and rotation the
multiplication in case of B Fe involves
some relatively heavy basically
operations related to this tensor
product and then it's followed by key
switching rotation is pure kiss region
and in the case of bfv we can see that
in fact the cost of actual
multiplication before case switching is
higher than it is the cost of key
switching and they only get comparable
to each other at basically the depth of
50 so something to take away that BFD
has an expensive form or multiplication
because we often look at the key
switching as being with a bottleneck it
is not in this case so just to maybe a
practicality remark and I think I've
already answered this question but what
do these numbers mean
I mean and concretely they mean that
this vfe implementation is used now in
commercial products of duality that's
encrypted see both query so what I'm
saying is that the numbers we're seeing
here are really practical practical to
expand that and that this technology can
be commercialized so you say that the
multiplication is the expensive
operation and what makes it expensive
you said is not a key switching it is
that it's the tensor product so we have
to multiply two cipher text without
modular reduction so we have to do CRT
bases which have to extend the basis
darkness basis which involves a lot of
entities we have to do the
multiplication this basically the double
bit with and then we have to scale it
down and all of this requires a number
of entities that is comparable even to
like the slowest case which you know
operations so it is the entity so what
carries anything inside that yes and it
is not there okay so let me just wrap up
this part you read is a clarification
question which is the number of
multiplication so that doesn't the
number of month
so it's so very often in these schemes
bgb be a physical yes we use the binary
tree technique which basically so it's
very furring to the depth of the binary
tree so it's I mean basically closer to
the second so to ^ basically you know is
the number of multiplications in a chain
that we can perform so so some notes on
so how did the HBS and BHT variants
compare based on the state of the art so
thanks to mean songs you try but I'll
post it has a very efficient
implementation of the DHT variant so we
can compare how basically they run and
for this snake of form and sizes of this
presentation did not present the tables
but the high level results of the
comparisons are the following the run
times of those two approaches are very
very similar and almost the same and the
main bottleneck is in the number of
entities and the number of entities is
roughly the same for both approaches so
this is after all state-of-the-art
optimizations applying to both variants
the noise growth is actually the same in
both variants so there and this was
noted recently between in the paper that
I mentioned and all those improvements
were added 2000 implemented so from the
noise those perspective these are
basically also equivalent each other
there is only one it might be
insignificant difference you think
usability difference which and we'll
talk more about these ability during
this talk later is the fact that HBS
variant is much simpler and I was
essentially able to explain most areas
in five or six slides while they
approach based on gamma reduction so on
is certainly much more challenging to
understanding implement but in terms of
run time and noise go there they're
essentially equivalent and just adjusted
implementation side note there are n s
procedures from both variants can be
mixed as needed so it's you know one
does not have to restrict basically one
way or inter the other they can be
so the next topic is going to be seeking
care so if there are any questions at
the moment related to be a fee I'm happy
to answer those if not I'm gonna go to
the next
okay so we'll focus so we had a nice
presentation yesterday from jung-soo
about Zika Kia's and so in this part of
the talk we're going to focus on the
challenges of our nurse variants of CPS
that also gives ability challenges and
in general of CA chaos and we're going
to present some ideas that improve and
so the a big challenge in the RNs
variants of CPS is modulus switching so
modulus switching is not new it was used
in BGP for instance to control the noise
here it has a slightly different meaning
so in secreteatory scaling so we call
Delta the risk and factor this ratio q
uppercase to lowercase corresponds to
the scaling factor that's used in
encoding certain like let's say
floating-point data so it actually is
meaningful it has a certain meaning of
the scale of the message and in the
original multi precision CK chaos code I
think the textbook Zika gets in a couple
of places this Delta is typically a
power of two which is very convenient
for many reasons and both uppercase Q
and lowercase Q are power of two in RNA
as variants of a chi scheme since we
have to perform the number 30 transform
efficiently that's that's our goal
this to moduli already composed into
products of small perhaps and and
typically this lowercase Q divides
uppercase Q and the operation of
rescaling insidious requires scaling
down by this Delta basically to the
power of P but we cannot use given the
constraints that we have for basically
for a lowercase Q and uppercase Q we
cannot choose something that's exactly
Majesty ^ feet
the best we can do is to find a small
prime that is close to dinner to the far
afield and based on this idea so just a
comment that's right there is an so
theoretically easy solution is like we
actually implemented in a little while
ago you don't have to just scale by a
single prime you can multiply by one
prime and divided by another all right
so you can have if you want to drop it
down by just two bits for example you
can multiply it by a prime 40 bits and
and and then divided by a prime of 42
bits and you'll get the same result it's
a little more expensive while you do the
operation but it actually lets you do
any kind of fine grained precision that
you need in the computation and in many
computation it's worth doing that yeah
thank you for this remark sure and I
think it might be that I get to come
back to you know more detailed
discussion because I'm going to present
so it's slightly different way of
handling this problem and maybe it would
be interesting to actually compare the
approaches and we get from them mmm-hmm
thank you thank you for the remarkable
certainly get back to so in the initial
CT case R&S variance and essentially the
one that was implemented and here are
this and this approximation was treated
as an extra noise and in a chilli it was
found a little bit different and we'll
we'll come back to it a little bit later
and they are an S module iqi are chosen
such that two to the power of P divided
by Q I stays in the range of 1 minus 2
to the power of minus Q 2 until 1 plus 2
minus epsilon where to minus epsilon is
kept as small as possible so base for
this each one's uses a metric of how
many basically beats we're basically
painting for the operation and maybe a
simpler way to look at it when we
therefore
the first multiplication in the rescale
operation our effective scaling factor
changes from the initial factor of K to
the power of P it changed since 2 to the
power of 2 P as a result of
multiplication and then divided by Q L
where else in this case just last
modules so we're doing from the very
start and we divide it by that as part
of rescaling so effectively the risk
going factor changes from to PT it's the
power of T P divided by Q L and it's
simple to show using this kind of
notation that we introduced the
approximation error of roughly P minus
epsilon bits and the idea that at least
was used in palisade and approximate
variant and I would imagine similar idea
was used to see in them Ernest a variant
of here is to alter that alpha make the
modular around 2p to minimize the error
so there is some cancellation of error
but not perfect cancellation because
we're dealing with Prime's with certain
constraints still the error keeps
growing as we increase the ring
dimension and the art of computation and
in those scenarios we've observed that
the risky or approximation essentially
dominates over this ridiculous noise we
can even disregard its noise and
estimate the approximation they are
based on just rescaling itself and the
question we posed can we avoid this
approximation inner and so I'm going to
get in the discussion of an alternative
or inners very that's available in
powers I actually think it's available
since November but we haven't had a
chance to write it up anywhere and so
this is joint work within 20 spot imager
and the question the answer to the
question of can we do better
I mean I already said we can do better
but in this case yes we can eliminate
the approximation error but the coast
can be too hard
so the rescaling ear is deterministic
and depends only on 2p and the module IQ
eyes there are involved in this so we
can always adjust the scaling factor by
certain extra multiplication
so in naive solution would be to do this
adjustment to multiply by a scaling
factor after every multiplication and we
can basically preserve let's say the
original scaling factor of TP by
carefully choosing the adjustment
factors but the challenge here
essentially we're introducing one extra
level so we have to do one more scale
multiplication followed by another
rescale so conceptually speaking this
naive solution would double the number
of levels and make this approach highly
inefficient compared to the
approximately can we do better than this
and this is the question we're trying to
answer it with Antonis and we'll walk
through several challenges that we ran
into
well answering this question so the
first challenge how can we efficiently
just the scaling factors minimizing the
performance constant in other words we
do not want to use it in a solution we
want to do something better and the
answer to this question is if we use the
natural or order of CK Kia's and nature
of meaning we start with a certain
scaling factor and then we just compute
the scaling factors for further levels
by implying multiplication and division
by the basically current a prime modulus
that's what we call the natural order we
can avoid many of those scalar
multiplications and we would only need
to perform scalar multiplications in
situations when we deal with ciphertex
at different levels only in that case we
would have to adjust them but the
important part is each level has a
different scaling factor not the same
scaling factor of T to the power of P as
an approximate variant and there is a
one minor optimization we applied here
to eliminate some extra
scaling we we could choose the first
modules to be ul not to ^ 3 in this case
okay so we have a solution that's more
efficient but now we're introducing this
relatively complex logic
what's a when we want to add this
for texture better currently different
levels and how can we Scott us hide the
scaling factor adjustments from the
users a sequin we do them automatically
because we don't want to expose another
complication to view and the our
solution for this problem was that first
we keep track of the scaling factors for
each level so we can you know easily
multiply by the appropriate scaling
factor one needed we automatically
adjust the scaling factor when needed so
it's an automated so it's a widely
capability not something that the user
has to think about and we also need want
to automatically rescale and this is
necessary for this theorem to enforce
the natural order scaling factors
otherwise there would be as many
combinations of scaling factors so
automated rescaling is something that's
certainly very useful for this approach
so challenge number three okay so now we
got the automated risk in which
obviously is a problem yeah so so the
scaling factor is is dictated by the
underlying computation right it says you
know when you multiply how many bits do
I drop
is that right yes so it's they're
different so I would say there are
different high level approaches to this
problem so one way is to to use a
granular metric and that allows you to
for example minimize the size of few
that you can use and I mean I believe
that's what it's done made you leap
the other approach is more I would say
simplify it is that you work with the
same scaling factor throughout the
computation roughly the same I mean this
case we still we still maintain that and
and you assume that basically this level
of weight let's call it similar to
32-bit or 64-bit mate event that there
won't be any basically normal force of
this particular size is sufficient so
it's so it's it's maybe like pushing the
problem a little bit like in
oversimplifying it but being more
conservative in allowing more bits that
that's how probably classifier also you
know I I mean if you think about it from
a point of view of somebody wanting to
use the secret KS they don't
particularly care about scaling factors
I mean what they know is you know there
are inputs maybe something about the
size of intermediates and the type of
outputs that you want and the accuracy
that they want they don't care how much
you scale intermediate computations
there okay see so you're saying the ways
to adjust these scaling factors that are
or crypto friendly will have sort of a
cross implications but that's something
to you know yeah I would actually
support what sure I said yesterday that
yes this rescaling this you know all
these challenges were city cares
is a problem but it should be a problem
for us I mean for what say in this case
all it was a library developer we should
not make any problem the user we should
use some automated logic that basically
hides this and that's that's the
approach that's used here as well so
this is we're looking from the
perspective how to make it usable and
it's and that's that may be partially
motivation
we don't want to expose that native
complexity of CBS okay maybe I'll
consider just so you're saying you know
watch it to come up with these
parameters these scaling factors right
and then what should you know you really
want to know what effect this has on the
accuracy of the final model or so the
convergence time or whatever so this
you're saying do a plain text you know
fix these parameters and then one can do
plain text experiments on maybe a small
subset of data or something to figure
out exactly exactly
I mean if you have a certain model for
the CGI scheme you can run those
computations and you can worry or you
can even come up with some theoretical
estimates but they're much harder to
derive so that's the idea given this
basic where scaling factor what can you
get at the end for a certain computation
so sorry are you worried this is how can
I ask another question on the previous
slide sure maybe a would it be possible
for me to finish with just describing
the algorithm here then I'm happy to
answer all those questions just just so
we at least finish okay let me know when
I should ask sure
okay so what logic should be used for
automated risk killing because obviously
that's by itself a problem for even the
textbook city chaos and what we chose as
the solution is to do the rescale
automatically right before the next
multiplication so we're not going so
let's say we have one multiplication
followed by certain operations for
selling rotations or additions or
something else and then a little bit
later we do another multiplication so
our for the automated rescaling we chose
the option of doing the rescale right
before that basically following
multiplication and the motivation for
this is that we perform all computations
between these two multiplications using
the noise budget that we get from the
prior multiplication
and what this means that many
intermediate operations become almost
noise free and it's a big challenge in
turn for example for rotations in
certain history techniques such as baby
kiss fishing so we're able to at least
kind of like I simulate that noise that
comes from those intermediate
computations into the noise budget of
the previous for multiplication and
there is a minor cost in performance for
this because effectively we're not going
to risk you immediately but we're going
to keep one more prime basically that
typically gets drop is on every scaling
until the very end until we need the
next multiplication but to be honest
that cost is not very significant
because when we were special but with a
large number of primes so then there was
another challenge and so with this
scaling factors that are different for
each level we noticed that after
performing a certain because this is the
scaling factor computation means
squaring and division squaring division
every time for every level we for after
a certain relatively small number of
levels of there's 1520 we observe how
these scaling factors diverge either in
the direction of 0 or infinity in other
words a certain point they become
useless to us while we may not care
about the exactly the scale effectively
want to stay within at least one beat of
the original I mean like let's say
scaling to the power of P factory so our
solution for this was to choose this
small Prime's Qi in a way that the
difference between these scaling factors
for each level are minimal so so the
procedure that is prolonged here I'm not
going to go and all the details but the
idea is we said we start with a certain
scaling factor like a drone in this case
and then we choose all other prime
moduli for the following levels in a way
that
minimizes they call it the error
basically in choosing the next scaling
factor so so that the scaling factor
stay as close to each other as possible
for basically many levels and from the
practical perspective we rent I mean we
did not provide and we didn't do any
theoretical estimates yet but from a
regular perspective or something like 2
to the power of 16 we saw that this
variant could still support let's say 80
90 levels without any problems obviously
for smaller ring dimensions this would
be the number of levels is higher so for
all practical reasons this would be
sufficient so I'll try to fast pace this
a little bit to just so I could answer
some questions related to yes so the
file level stories this the rescaling
air in the exact terminus parent is
basically very similar to the air in the
tenth pcp care so at least we solve that
problem and the matter of fact that we
get output precision which is very
similar yes precision then the other
problem we have to solve but it's very
useful from the usability perspective s
is that rescaling and modulus switching
but here i'm referring to the modulus
switching using the original CPS paper
so level reduction without changing the
scale in this variant are done
automatically so if in other words any
adjustment of scaling factors rescaling
modulus which if they're all done
automatically the user does not speed
them the user does never never calls
rescale directly and of course there is
a certain cost but in our goal was to
minimize that performance cost and
depending on the computation the
difference in speed that we saw between
the approximate
Ernest variant and the exact Ernest
variant is it ranges between 1.1 X to
1.5 X so it's it's I would say it's not
dramatic it's it's in my opinion it's a
reasonable cost for a much simpler
version CPS and we get much
our precision so yeah this is a good
topic to sum up I can just answer some
questions so you could you go back to
the slide about the different scaling
factors per level this is hop yeah this
one so Alice just wondering because in
some cases you could end up with
separate eggs on the same level but they
they still have different scaling
factors right so it depends on the order
of operations you do to arrive at that
level so that's why automatic rescaling
is introduced okay so if such control we
control the how risk is done that's
that's how we're so no problem until you
get a little bit more detail about how
you control it that was actually in the
slides right after this I mean I'm happy
to repeat it but this is exactly what I
was discussing how we actually do it
electricity on so how maybe for the sake
of time is it okay if I just continue
and then I'm happy to explain this in
more detail fine check questions yes so
inside
first question instead of using the
original Delta as the scale factor we
used different factors for each level
that is absolutely correct I mean that's
that's what we're doing and we're doing
it essentially to preserve the natural
order and I mean the scale factor itself
doesn't matter too much as long as we
keep basically work with the same number
of bits about the way it wants to
basically eliminate or minimize the air
that's introduced is okay so is there
still a way to Manuel imaginary scale so
yeah this is a good question question of
optimization so in the approximate
version of course you provide the
ability for the user to manually rescale
in the exact version it gets a little
bit trickier because one could break
that logic of how the scaling factors
are chosen so that's that's why we so so
we use the approach that we take care of
the rescaling to minimize the situations
when you know there is an issue due to
the optimizations okay I'll try to very
quickly go through a couple of slides
because it looks like time I swear we're
on you know just there's some other
interesting results to share but very
different so so keeps Michigan CES and
BGP so you briefly touch that there are
several different key switching
techniques that can be used and all of
the direction fermented in power state
and this is more of a guideline just
based on our current understanding the
state of our choices for key switching
is for the earnest take a position
overall for key switching in RLS that is
specific to see case in pgb here's
basically there are two methods that are
most relevant so when the number of
levels is relatively small and we
typically the so called
bv digit the composition but they are an
S version of it is the fastest the only
basically got you there is that it may
introduce some
significant noise when doing rotations
there is a workaround for that too but
that's that's the only consideration
when we get into deeper computation the
best key switching technique that's
available is essentially what's called
as hybrid keep switching and it's it's a
combination of the basically just keep
switching with our des decomposition
it's much faster for deeper computations
for sure it doesn't reduce a medullary
modulus all the requirements from the LW
perspective are a little bit different
but it does not have the noise issues
that they may be that basically the
media switching has it from the
performance perspective this is not a
big issue for VF e r4 because
multiplication is often constant in case
which is but it can be an issue when
basically dealing with noise so this is
it might be an interesting result
I think it's relatively trivial for
basically well when you have those both
VG and V Fe available so this particular
table compares but the runtimes for BG b
and b fe imperative or both RNs variants
for a computation that is a chain of
basically ^ f minus 1 from amorphic
multiplications so it's like a binary
tree multiplication in this case this
was of course this is a very special
computation that was chosen to highlight
the advantages of BGP but maybe to give
some thought the fact that homomorphic
multiplication is expensive in bf3 here
makes VG be better from the efficiency
perspective option when basically you
know when a lot of moderate
multiplications are involved and the
extent to which this is true so we look
here at depths from 2 to 6 and 6
essentially I mean corresponds to a
large number of all we have an speed-up
ranging from 1.3 x 2 and I want to take
careful to 5x
because I think that very first choices
it's probably very special but there is
a performance increase using confusing
between R and s for the computations
that wormhole modifications illy
question do you have any kind of results
for really deep circuits that 4080 it's
yeah probably the computation would have
to be different I didn't I did not run
them but it's very so I think the trend
can be seen from this from this table as
we increase the depth the effect becomes
less significant because the key
switching starts dominating more and
more and actually what we saw in there
in the vfv table previously so I would
say it's it's going to get the ratio is
going to get basically closer I mean to
1 and at some point even B if you might
be more beneficial but but yeah I did
not run those experience but that's kind
so it's it's but it's a very good remark
that for deeper computations the result
might differ
it won't ask pretty much the same
question and actually you know what is
the crossover point you give interesting
tools or figure it out let's let's let's
cause an open question I did not run
exhaustive computations yes let's call
it open but it's an interesting question
and in my opinion both teams are very
useful
yeah in practice and of course the
complaints that are used so very briefly
this is the main majors out and other
things is just pointers to the previous
publications on our state implementation
so I'll focus on this major resultant I
think we can stop at that so a few
verses tfhe so very recently Daniel and
myself examined both schemes and try to
compare the scheme should understand the
differences between them and it's there
is a paper on this immigrant but I'll
just highlight the main finding so when
instantiated using lwl I believe both
teams are essentially the same
except for the bootstrapping procedure
so in other words the use of tourists is
not necessary that's that's a convenient
encoding basic technique but in terms of
the basic underlying algorithms the main
difference is in the bootstrapping
technique of course there were other
optimizations that are applied later in
the G fhe papers and some enhancements
such as circuit bootstrapping our
analysis shows that all of those
techniques can be equally applied to few
an TF hu so that's so so in other words
it's a it's the same family so they're
very similar even the one could combine
to put certain procedures if needed then
one another might be an important result
of this paper he shows that although the
original th is explicitly formulated for
binary secret distributions and which
you know are still kind of being
discussed at this point how I mean
whether they basically where the binary
secrets are considered a very secure the
scheme itself is not limited to that
show so it we show that how it can be
extended to turn around - in series and
in terms of its behavior with different
secrets it's and we show the trade-off
showing into the on the x-axis we're
going work a different secret key
distributions starting from binary going
up to the Gaussian theoretical and it's
interesting to note that run time wise
the few and tfhe cross at basic a
ternary distribution I'm in ternary
secret distribution so then and
something they're just two different
options shown here for a few depending
on the digit side that's chosen then
afterwards the few which is based on IP
based bootstrapping becomes actually
faster but there is a another side is
the most driving key size and
it's a the most charming procedure the
jinx booster consider using trhe as
major advantages over that and we can
see that if the good serving size is a
concern then they would be preferred the
jinx approach would be referred in the
case of gaussian secrets or both
practical and theoretical the
distinction is really not clear depends
on what weather run time is the main
metric or the size is the main metric so
there are more results but I would say
the other results are published and I'm
happy to share the slides just very
quick because of the time but you know
you're 9 minutes over so we reached so a
very brief I'll just go through those
just that there are some protocols
related to lettuce gadgets and
information about policy and I'll share
the slides and then thank you okay so
the question so I'll try to so it's 40
12 so that's both of you once again
sensors let's let's actually Thank You
REE and URI will be will take questions
in the next five or so minutes and we'll
reconvene in in about five ish minutes
with Peter show thank you I'll try to be
very quick so those palisade
implementable stirring for city s the
public where the policy does not
currently have was reading for CBS the
plan is being discussed is bootstrapping
in palisade faster than tfhe leap no
it's not the implementation in palisade
does not use a DX extensions doesn't
basically we try to stay as generic as
possible but if any extensions are used
rs always in the show that there are
going to be roughly the same I mean
what's it for the binary secret then for
the practical commercial applications
for the palisade library how large for
the database it can be supported what
type of queries I can perform I think
it's it's hard to answer this question
in a very concise manner I mean I want
to try to take it offline and please
send me an email and a better
explanation of this what is the proxy
like or encryption technique upon the
palisade so the idea is that we can
leverage key switching the same key
switching technique that was discussed
in the context of BGP
NCP is to switch from one key to an item
in publisher subscriber environment and
this is very similar to the approach to
encryption that you might have seen in
non lattice constructions and baggies
and there's there different flavors
unidirectional for instance and the
ideas in the publisher subscriber you
can change the key under which
ciphertext can be decrypted through this
process and this is employed and
palisaded but internal it uses the same
mechanisms confession so let's say let's
thank you again and Peter maybe you can
start setting up